- Hey, gang.
Dave Baker here,
and these are some
of my favorite short swords
featured on "Forged in Fire."
[music playing]
In close quarters,
in tight spaces,
often a long weapon is more
of a liability than a help.
That's why throughout
history, different cultures
have developed short swords to
fight in those tight spaces.
This oddly bent
weapon is the sica.
Now, the sica was
originally a Thracian weapon
which was based on the
agricultural tool the sickle.
The Roman gladiatorial version
put the steep bend in it
so it could be used to
dig in and grab a shield
and allow that shield to
be pushed out of the way
before the attack is made.
This double edged, heavy blade
was a devastating weapon.
Now, this beautiful, slightly
curved weapon is the yatagan.
The yatagan was
the primary weapon
of the Turkish Janissaries.
These weapons were in
use from the 14th century
to the 19th century.
The slight curve
towards the front
makes it a fantastic
shopping weapon,
yet the point is developed
enough for the thrust.
Many of these weapons had ivory
handles inlay mother of pearl.
Some of the most decorated
weapons from the period.
It's a light, fast,
extremely mobile weapon.
In the hands of a Janissary,
it would be terrifying.
Now, this deadly blade is the
Roman gladius, one of the most
iconic short swords in history.
It's the sword of the
Roman legions, the sword
that lasted 600 years.
Until recently, we haven't
had many actual pieces
that survived.
What we've been
relying on of course
are either sculptures
or pottery depicting
soldiers using this weapon.
Now, they're usually
depicted with the weapon
in the right hand
and a large shield
or scutum in the left hand.
And that follows Roman
military doctrine,
which usually said
that you had to thrust
with the blade horizontal.
Now, that allowed it to go
up under or through armor
or between the ribs.
The proof of this
weapon's effectiveness
is shown in the many years it
was used by the Roman legions.
This is the naval
cutlass designed
specifically for naval warfare.
Back in the days
of the tall ship,
the ships were tight with
ropes everywhere, cannons.
There was very little
room to swing a weapon.
A long blade would
be almost useless,
so a weapon was designed
specifically for that fight,
and that weapon was the cutlass.
It had a lot of hand protection.
You could deliver
blows with the guard.
The blade was
shortened down so it
could be swung in close
quarters either with a hack
or used to stab.
This cutlass is based on
the design which was adapted
by the United States
military and still issued
all the way to World War II.
Close quarters, small
weapon, but a big punch
and one of my favorites.
This is the xiphos, the
Greek warrior's sword.
It had this leaf blade
with a wasp waist
on it, which allowed
the weight to be forward
for serious chopping action.
It had an acute
tip for thrusting.
[swords clanging]
It had a guard that was
usually just big enough
to protect the hand
and a counterbalance
to balance all that weight out.
These weapons spanned
hundreds of years of time
on the battlefield and
probably influenced a lot
of the gladius' development.
Usually, the shield was
held in the left hand,
the xiphos in the right.
And often, the
shield had a cutout.
That allowed that
deadly, piercing point
to be used to its best
effect, a weapon that
truly passed the test of time.
So there you have
it, folks, some
of my favorite short swords
featured on "Forged in Fire."
If you have any questions, put
them in the comments below,
and I'll try to get to
them in a future video.